rishy sunak just been absolutely
walloped by a lot of his own party but
certainly by um most newspapers and most
broadcasters because um Rose bank has
been given the goahead that's the
biggest untapped field in the North Sea
that we know of uh and Rose bank is
about 80 miles off the shet off of
Shetland it's relatively accessible by
North Sea standards and now finally uh a
UK listed company Ithaca and the
Norwegian state energy giant equinor are
going to develop that field and it's got
300 million barrels of oil at least
right so that's enough to keep the whole
world going for three days which doesn't
sound a lot but but it is stands it's
absolutely huge and it's 8 billion quids
worth of investment is 2 and a half
thousand jobs as the gmbb union one of
our main unions keeps reminding the
labor party labor Fame you know in the
typical fashion they they don't agree
with what the Tories are doing on Rose
bank because that will upset their
environmental Lobby uh but they're not
going to reverse it uh because that
would upset their bluecollar you know
gmbb Union lobby who want those jobs for
their for their for their members but it
makes complete sense to me that we
should be using our own energy from the
North Sea I mean why because there's
something within the British uh
establishment now called the climate
change committee that's the government's
own in-house a green Watchdog that has
statutory powers to sort of push and go
and CH ministers if they're not doing
everything that they should be doing to
get us to Net Zero in 2050 even the
climate change committee admits that we
will be using oil and gas by the mid
2030s for 50% of all our energy right
even if Ren it's currently 70 by by the
way the climate change committee says it
will still be 50% of all our energy by
mid 203 and that's if the climate change
committee's own estimates for the take
up and efficiency of Renewables
the improvements they're in are met and
a lot of people think they won't be met
a lot of people think they're far too
Rosy and too optimistic so we'll be
lucky to be at only 50% oil and gas by
the mid 2030s it'll probably be higher
and even the climate change committee
they say that when we are at Net Zero in
2050 then we'll still be using oil and
gas for around 25% of all our energy so
if we're going to use oil and gas use
our own because it's cheaper it means we
get the jobs the tax revenue and the
prosperity and it's far less carbon
intensive what's the alternative the
alternative is you drill gas in Dakota
you put it through a pipeline to an LG
terminal in the state you you liquefy it
which is massively carbon and energy
intensive you put it in a tanker that
goes 3,200 mil across the Atlantic
diesel powered by the way and then you
reg gasify at Milford Haven or somewhere
else in Mainland Europe all massively
energy intensive but at least we can
then tell ourselves oh this isn't our
carbon footprint but it is we have to be
smarter about this it makes huge sense
to use our own North Sea oil and gas
given that even under the most
panglossian the most uh Rosy assumptions
about our pathway towards Net Zero by
the climate change committee itself
we'll still be using an awful lot of oil
and gas for the rest of my life so
rather than just say as the Green Party
does this is morally obscene get real
you're going to need oil and gas at
least until 2050 probably for a lot
longer it's cheaper and it's more
environmentally friendly to use our own
but that's the thing is you're putting
forward a pragmatic
[Laughter]
argument